SEAN ROBINSON: So we have a
menu of about 20 experiments
in the lab.
Each student will
do three or four
over the course of a semester.
New experiments come
into lab every few years.
They usually start
with an idea, usually
coming from a faculty
member somewhere
in the Department of Physics.
Sometimes, the idea
for a new experiment
is something that was
in a research lab.
Sometimes it's just
something that's
a classic technique which has,
say, become a standard thing
that the graduate students in
a particular professor's lab
have to do on a routine basis--
getting that into a mold that
works within the structure
of our semester, where
students are typically
spending about two weeks
performing the experiment.
We want an experiment
in this lab
to be something
which doesn't simply
work when you turn it on.
We want the students to
have to cause it to work.
We don't want people to simply
turn the apparatus on and get
data.
We want them to cause the
apparatus to give good data.
That usually means
there's something
they have to calibrate.
It usually means
there's lots of settings
on various parts of
the apparatus, which
some of the settings give bad
data and some of the settings
give good data.
And the students constantly
have to be going back and forth
between some preliminary
analysis and data
taking in order to
evaluate whether or not
the data they've
collected is good,
whether the settings they've
set on their apparatus
are any good.
Getting a piece of
apparatus, which
has been designed
by a faculty member,
as a beautiful piece
of research apparatus
which works in a reliable way,
in the hands of an expert,
and getting into something which
a student, who is seeing it
for the first time,
can operate in a way
where they have enough
intellectual space
on the apparatus that they can
explore it, and understand how
different parts of it work or
don't work, and yet still have
it be robust enough that
it, say, doesn't break.
It will work consistently
from one roughly
two week period when a certain
student group is working on it
to when the next student
group is working on it.
That tends to be more
of a design challenge.
We get into a routine
back and forth
between the faculty
member who's championing
the experiment and
the technical staff
really understanding what
parts of an experiment
have to be changed.
And then, ultimately,
someone has
to write a manual
for the experiment.
There's a model we've been
using for the past few years
where we get an
experiment to the point
where we think it's a pretty
good piece of apparatus
that a student will be able to
learn a lot by performing it.
Yet we still don't have
any manual written for it,
no instructions or anything.
So if a new student were to just
walk up to it at that point,
it would be really a
research project for them
to get it working.
Within the structure
of Junior Lab,
we actually do have some
room for that type of thing.
And the second semester
of Junior Lab, which
is Subject 8.14, one of the
experiments the students have
to perform in the
course of the semester
is not simply something from our
menu of roughly 20 experiments,
but it's something they
have to develop themselves.
They have to write a proposal,
get that proposal approved
by the funding committee, which
is the staff in Junior Lab,
and then, ultimately,
perform that experiment,
analyze the data, and then
present it to their peers.
We have a poster session that
we close out the semester
with in that course.
So something that has been
useful for the past few years
when we've developed
a new experiment
is we try to find one of
these student groups in 8.14
who volunteers to
perform that experiment
without any guidance,
without any manual.
They run it through,
basically, as beta testers,
from our point of view, and tell
us which things worked well,
which things didn't work well.
And 100% of the time so
far, when we've tried this,
the students always
discover something new
that that apparatus can do,
some new physics measurement
that we didn't think of.
And those new discoveries
by the students
who perform that the first
time, without any guidance,
inevitably, those become
part of the manual
that eventually future students
use as the standard manual
going forward.